we had a great meeting all of the
Republican senators were there I think
we made tremendous progress on a lot of
different issues we have a lot of very
positive things happening both in terms
of the country in terms of the election
that's coming up President Trump right
there after yesterday's closed-door
lunch with Senate Republicans reports
indicating the November elections topped
the agenda with the president urging
lawmakers to toughen up against the
Democrats my next guest was there for
the lunch joining me now while me
senator John Barrasso chair of the
Senate Republican Committee good morning
to you senator thanks ed what was going
on behind closed doors because Kellyanne
Conway just told us the president's
ready to get back on the trail he's
ready to transition back to some of
those rallies maybe with a little bit of
social distancing and that we're hearing
that behind closed doors yesterday he
was boasting about his poll numbers and
basically saying let's take on the Obama
administration and what happened with
surveillance and he's feeling good
heading into this election your thoughts
the president was very positive very
optimistic focused on the future focused
on getting people back to work getting
the country open again and getting the
disease behind us in terms of the
successes that we've had with vaccines
as well as treatment and testing so
there was a very positive meeting
focused specifically on the future he
did talk about the upcoming elections
and the need for us to be strong and
smart and tough in fighting the
Democrats because we know what they have
a tendency to want to do we see their
PlayBook in the Nancy Pelosi three
trillion-dollar big I think terrible
basically it is their playbook for 2020
when you look at the whole list of
things that she is offering as basically
a play a payoff to the political left
that's what this is it's very partisan
and it's not focused on getting our
country open again in any sort of a
targeted or timely or temporary way I
want to get to that stimulus in a moment
it's very important obviously to get the
economy back on track but quickly on the
politics there have been several reports
suggesting that you and other Senate
Republicans are very nervous about the
president's re-election prospects and
that you
could lose control of the Senate and
November 2 that come up yesterday how
concerned are you
well the concerns about the Senate are
that we have 23 Republicans who are up
and only a dozen Democrats so absolutely
you have to focus on that the margin is
slim right now because the president was
key to point out that if the Democrats
take control of the Senate the Chuck
Schumer will change the rules on day one
to make it harder to get things done in
a second Trump administration we know
that the Democrats have tried to do
they've continued to road block the
president's appointments we still have
over a hundred appointees in year four
that haven't gone through so we know how
important it is to make sure that not
just as president Trump get reelected
but we hold a Senate Republican majority
yeah so that we can continue to confirm
the conservative judges and we've done
over 200 so far well guess what senator
we have a teed up a soundbite from that
gentleman you mentioned Chuck Schumer he
says you're not focused enough on a new
stimulus bill let's listen to him and
give you a chance to respond for the
third week in a row the Republican
majority in the Senate has no kovat
related business on the agenda there are
now more than 35 million Americans out
of work through no fault of their own
almost 1.5 million Americans are sick
nearly 90,000 have died and Senate
Republicans have decided to take the
monk month off from the coronavirus
senator I get it I know you did you and
your colleagues believe Chuck Schumer is
gonna be partisan about this on the
other hand you and your colleagues have
been open about saying you want to take
a pause here can you really pause on
stimulus when over 35 36 million people
are unemployed right now well as you
know at only about half of the money
that we've already approved has gone out
there's another hundred million for a
hundred billion for hospitals there's
another hundred billion available in the
paycheck protection plan there's a
hundred and fifty billion that has gone
to the states that has not yet been
spent
I think they need more flexibility in
how they do it but anything we need to
do in terms of additional efforts needs
to have included in that legislation
liability protection
so there are small businesses the
mom-and-pop businesses around the
country have some protection against the
the suin set of lawyers who are already
sharpening their knives to go after them
so we may need another bill but I will
tell you in terms of what Senator
Schumer said I mean the chair the
committee that I chair the Environment
and Public Works Committee we just
passed the major water infrastructure
bill the president has talked to me
about infrastructure our committee has
passed a highway infrastructure bill and
now just in the last weeks a water
infrastructure bill for our dams our
ports that gets people back to work that
puts dollars in the States and people on
the job last 30 seconds we have you
started by going after Nancy Pelosi's
plan which as you know includes stimulus
money for illegal immigrants her
pushback is these are folks who were
here illegally but they are paying taxes
they're working they're paying taxes
into the system how do you fix all this
so are you gonna buy that that they're
paying in the system are you gonna say
they're here illegally they're not
getting any new money no I disagree with
Nancy Pelosi a hundred percent actually
she's making it easier for illegal
immigrants to work in her three trillion
dollar bill that Fantasyland bill then
she's making it easier for American the
36 million Americans out of work to get
back on the job that are those are the
perverse incentives that she's included
in this liberal wish list
Senator John Barrasso appreciate your
thoughts this morning thank you sir